our friend Joel Klat from Fox Sports
who's been all over this college
football world and of course spent a
great year last year part of the NFL
Network draft coverage in Nashville and
I look forward to doing it again with
him real soon he is now on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Joel clad good
but how are you better for talking to
you man I hope you and your family
everybody's fine in your world
everyone's doing really really good in
my world thankfully and I got to tell
you what an event last night rich right
I mean the the draft in and of itself
really is about hope optimism and
building for the future yep
was there a better event for the period
in time that we needed as a country then
last night and you know a lot of
executives remember didn't want to do
the draft when they first announced that
they were gonna do it on schedule and I
talked with a lot of them yesterday the
last couple of days there and all of
them two men said glad we're doing then
okay right time we need to get out there
no kidding so many of the evaluators
were like why are we doing this it's not
the way that we're used to doing it I
prefer to wait or we're all like glad
we're doing it a hundred percent
to a man and to their credit man it came
off pretty clean I was worried
first pickle difficulties but other than
the the ROG stumbling over a few things
and misplacing a year here and there
with with Vegas in particular it went
pretty well it was it was it was it went
very well and then on our NFL Draft a
thon live stream it was a total blast
and people could check it out on nfl.com
right now and I'll be back there at 7:00
Eastern Time tonight new surge olk lat
you're a busy man yourself let's get
right into the conversation of the
moment do you like the pic of Jordan
Love by Green Bay to trade up four spots
to go get them do you like that no I I
don't and you know partly because this
is not a team that went eight and eight
was an old quarterback you know I I'm a
big believer in any sport but in
particular and in the modern era in all
professional sports when you've got to
respect championship windows and and
when they come around and when you've
got a player that can lead you to a
championship you have to respect
oh by the way you know it reminds me of
the last dance that we're watching now
and it's like ha how do you not allow
them to at least earn it on the court
right I mean speaking of the bowls of
the 90s to me you're one game away from
the Super Bowl
in Green Bay one game and the last time
I checked Aaron Rodgers wouldn't the
problem in San Francisco it was the fact
that Mozart is still running and Jimmy
Garoppolo had to throw like negative 47
passes he was like a barrel of oil right
yeah I mean like he didn't have to do
anything and there were some defensive
players there that they could have
gotten that I think are really good
players namely those two linebackers
that went right after them in subsequent
picks Jordan Brooks from Texas Tech
Patrick Queen from LSU so I understand
building for the future some people are
saying hey they're gonna get you know
they've got all these picks in the
middle of the draft they can build there
yeah but you got to respect the
championship window and now you're going
to just make Aaron Rodgers more dishevel
which is not fun yeah I kind of I mean
if you want to make it even worse to and
I pointed out before I mean the Niners
the team that you were talking about the
quarterback that was leaking like a
barrel of oil they went from a position
behind from where the Packers moved up
to move up in a spot that eventually was
one before where the Packers would move
up to to take Brandon ioq and give him
to Garoppolo which is Brandon oh and
here's the thing talking with some of
their people you know anybody that was
around and and this by the way remains
the same with with Lafleur Laurel in
Green Bay but also Kyle Shanahan is that
when they watch Brandon Ayub they saw
Pierre Garcon because they had touched
him previously
and so Shanahan had Iuka as his top
receiver on the board right like it was
yuck or CD lamb and so from his
standpoint he not only goes and gets a
weapon that he deemed a position of need
the top wide receiver amongst that
position on his board
but it's clearly something that maybe
they straw
it's right you could even say in the
Super Bowl they needed another target it
couldn't just be Kittel all day long for
Jimmy Garoppolo they needed a wide
receiver and now with some of the exits
that they've had in the offseason they
needed to fill fulfill that position to
respect the championship window and they
did it with the guys they like you kid
no one can say from Green Bay that that
pick made them better for next year
that's the problem joke lot here on the
Rich Eisen show and then channel your
inner quarterback so how do you think
Rogers truly is feeling right now cuz
we're hearing Brian go to Kunst has not
spoken to him and that could be read in
many different ways
because goda Kunst is not gonna come out
and say well i tried him three times and
i got sent to voicemail three times so
he's if I say something like that how do
you how do you think Rogers truly does
feel right now
well imagine for a moment to make this a
really bad reference imagine just for a
moment you're like you're Jeff Gordon
and you're prime and they give you a car
that is not as good as everybody else's
car and they expect you to go win the
Daytona 500 how would you feel right I
mean give them some weapons it's like
Brady with New England it so I think
it's what probably soured his
relationship in New England it's like
you want me to do what with what guys
you know like you got to give me
something here
you know we won the Super Bowl in New
England and then you gave me nothing to
work with and this is the product of
that and and I think that Rodgers has
got to be feeling the same way he had to
have felt like they're in prime position
to select one of these really quality
wide receivers and they were unable to
do that and this is a deep brand wide
receiver I'm sure we're gonna grab one
from a Green Bay perspective later today
but if how is Rodgers out being sensed I
don't have forever to play and you're
gonna stick Jordan love behind me I
needed a wide receiver and then in
response to that all you gave me was
more reporters with more microphones in
my face asking me about something I
don't want to talk about which is my
backup quarterback no starter wants to
be asked about his backup ever period
joke lot here on the Rich Eisen show I
knew you'd have the perspective that
would be fresh and interesting and
the tool pick let's get to the tool pick
right now do you like that over Herbert
because I'm assuming but we shouldn't
even talk about burrow because that was
such the no-brainer number one overall
correct yeah that's that's right and
tend to me I was too over Herbert just
because I think that when when you look
at him play he does the things that I
think translate namely rich he
anticipates Windows he makes quick
decisions in particular when throwing
the football over the middle he's a
quick release guy he's a short lever
quarterback meaning that you know he's
not just going to sit there you have to
protect him so he can throw the football
down the field with a long motion long
limbs he can be compact a very breeze
like get the football out with
accuracies a quality passer obviously
with accuracy on time on target equals
yards after catch all of those things
are great for me
he's only got to change one thing rich
about his game and I think he can have a
long career he thinks he's more elusive
than he is therefore he holds on to the
ball when he's trying to evade but he
can't evade completely and so he gets
rolled up on from behind that's how he
heard both of his ankles that's how he
fractured his it if he can play more in
the vein of Drew Brees which his head
coach was trying to tell people that's
who he is if you can play more like
Brees unless like Wilson he can play for
a long time and be very effective I
think Miami's gonna be really happy and
I know again because the quarterbacks
that's that that's the the bright shiny
object nobody's really talking about
chase young today and boy did you and
Gus see a ton of chase young on Fox how
transformative do you think he can be in
this league well I I did I have to say
it this way I I think he's better than
Bosa I think he's better than Nick VOSA
because he's longer he's got all of the
explosiveness he's got all of the energy
he's got the drive the motor the skills
the hands the quick hands and and yet
he's a he's a longer player and that
length I think helps him in particular
in the run game chase chase is a dynamic
guy and just a quick story and
I saw a lot of them last year and over
the last couple of years but a few years
ago I went to a spring practice at Ohio
State and it was one of the first times
I went to a spring practice there after
fox had gotten the contract to do big
ten games
wanted to spend some time with Coach
Meyer and I wanted to see the team and
so I go out there and guess who the
early enrollee freshmen are on the field
Jeff Okuda chase young JK Dobbins and
guess who
JK Dobbins is working with offensively
in Okuda and and chase young are working
against from the offensive perspective I
guess a quarterback Joe you have Joe
Blow and you know I think back to that
day and I was so excited to just be able
to you know check out a new program that
I hadn't seen live and talk with Coach
Meyer and I wanted to see Nick Bosa and
the first few steps on the field I
looked over and I and I looked at Gerry
emic who's they're terrific s ID and I
said Jerry who in God's name is number
two I was like what is that because
that's freakish he was a true freshman
should have been a senior in high school
mm-hmm so fast forward into the fall I'm
doing their game against Maryland
chase young walks onto the field it's
one of the first times he gets onto the
field at least in a game that I was
covering and so I immediately hit my
talkback button to my producer Chuck
MacDonald and I said give me some shots
of chase young right now I want to talk
about he says he hasn't done anything
like yet I said pull the cameras at
chase young so sure enough I said Gus I
hold up my hand - Gus which is like a
no-go you never hold your hand up - Gus
but I felt strongly about it Rhett right
like I had to get this out so before
chase takes the snap against Maryland I
go on and I gosh about and I think it's
online actually and I was like hey this
kid is unbelievable the 2020 NFL Draft
you're going to hear this kid's name
selected in the top five he was a true
freshman everyone's like what are you
talking about I'm here to see Mick Bosa
I'm like this kid is an absolute monster
on that snap chase young got his very
first snack sack in college football and
he never looked back and I think he's
gonna be a dominant player and I think
he has the potential to be one of the
great pass rushers that we see over the
next 10 years I love that story from
start to finish even though it's talking
about the Ohio State and it gets me very
upset because it makes me upset but that
said the one thing I really want to just
touch upon pull one
string before I finish up about tonight
is nobody gives the hand to Gus Johnson
is that what you just said Oh nobody
waves their hay yes right you should
have seen the look I got that was only
like our third year together you know
and you he looked at me and if chase
wouldn't have gotten a set I think I
would have heard about it afterwards
because it worked out and he got to make
this really nice colors like and and
partner your all over adjacent areas and
we got to build the star of Chase young
we go to the break and he goes he goes
you give me a fist bump me is like nice
yeah nice yeah I love it Joe glad here
on the Rich Eisen show let's go to
tonight who do you like that's on the
board right now as the for the rest of
the entire draft class and then focusing
on the quarterbacks what do you got for
me Joe yeah you know the quarterbacks
are gonna be interesting I think that
we're gonna see kind of this debate
amongst the NFL organizations that I've
been hearing in the next couple of
quarterbacks which i think is going to
fall between jaylen Hertz and Jake
Fromme I think those might be the next
two names that we hear off the board
from a quarterback perspective and then
when I look at it I see some running
backs they're about to go and maybe fast
deandre Swift from Georgia still on the
board you've got JK Dobbins from Ohio
State
you've got Jonathan Taylor from
Wisconsin
you've got cam akers from Florida State
all these guys very good players you
might see a run on them in the second
round and then some edge players that I
think that we're gonna see pretty early
tonight eat or grouse Matos from Penn
State likely gonna get selected pretty
quickly
you've got Marlin Davidson from Auburn
on the edge and then a JEP Anessa the
defense have been from Iowa check out
those names I feel like we're gonna hear
them pretty quickly
that's the poll question of Joel Clapp
before he sent him on his day
Christopher all right Joe who won the
first round
dolphins Cowboys 49ers Buccaneers
I'm gonna go 49ers it's just ever since
this guy John Lynch came into the league
as a Gao down he's been masterful in the
draft guys he really has he trade down
again and gets the guy that he targeted
in Javon Kinlaw then he goes up to get
the wide receiver that his head
covets so they in large part probably
got what they feel like is the number to
pass rusher or excuse me defensive
linemen in the draft and Jovanka in law
and then they get their number one wide
receiver in IU so I go to the 49ers I
think they had a great night yeah and he
also drafted debo Samuel last year just
just throw that one out there too and
everyone's looking for their own debo
tonight that's for sure in the second
round everyone was hoping to strike the
same gold and then you just move around
the draft board because they still got
Kinlaw by getting a fourth rounder from
Tampa which moved up to take worse and
many later flip that for to go and move
up and get iuck I mean that's the way
you work a draft board pretty much right
there's exactly right John Lynch again
and he does this every year it doesn't
it seem like we we just talked about how
he just is really good methodical when
it comes to the draft I'm glad you
didn't ask me about the Giants because I
don't want to repeat about what happened
last year well they got protection for
daniel Jones Joel they did and they over
drafted another player for the third
straight year but you know what if it
works out it works out and you know what
Giants not gonna criticize not here to
talk about the giant West which one do
you dislike more the daniel Jones pick
or the Jordan love my god the only thing
I was strong about with Jones is that I
felt like they could have got it was
more the values and it was the pick like
juicers was a first rounder for sure and
I just thought that they could have got
him with their second another they had
two picks I believe it was like 18 and
and five maybe something along those
lines are six yes and he took him with
the first one I just thought you know
what you could have gotten a great
defensive player and then he manipulated
the board to select Jones at 12 so I was
more upset with the value this one
though like really you're 60 minutes
from the Super Bowl most are still
running Garoppolo through eight passes
whatever it was and you drafted Jordan
love like what what are we doing it and
again he sees the team that beat him be
aggressive to get the receiver and then
he sees Brady's new team
go and get the the tackle to protect him
I mean just to put it all in perspective
but there is still six more rounds of
the draft we'll see who knows you never
know
I'll just throw that out there thanks
for the call Joel you the man I
appreciate it guys rich always great
talking with you enjoy but you too a
pleasure Joel CLAT who I should have
been working with in Las Vegas tonight
unfortunately just phoning in here on
the Rich Eisen show it hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here